in a documentary about the making of
Avatar director James Cameron revealed
that the original design for the navi
was much less graceful and Feline than
the aliens we see on screen because
Avatar is a love and assimilation story
where Jake Sully Falls for natiri and
becomes one of the navi the character
designers opted to make the navi
humanoid and exotically beautiful in the
documentary Cameron said I wanted people
to say I want to be one of them Cameron
told Gizmodo that he relied on feedback
from his crew of artists for this reason
adjusting the design until they felt it
was plausible that a human like Jake
could be attracted to one Cameron also
said that they emphasized the alien and
the animal a bit more in the older Navi
characters to make meeting the future
in-laws more frightening in an interview
with Playboy Cameron explained how he
designed naturi to appeal to his male
audiences ID he explained that the
heterosexual male perception of female
Beauty was extremely unrealistic and he
didn't expect male viewers to be grossed
out by the navi in light of this